avertissements nous avons voulu tester
la réalité virtuelle et partager cette
expérience avec vous nous n'avons aucun
intérêt ni partenariat avec playstation
bas d'ailleurs vous pourrez pas dire le
contraire parce que moi j'ai vraiment
pas du tout aimé ce truc enfin vous
allez voir go alors moi je suis plutôt
un rétro gamer le sabbat de final
fantasy megaman crash bandicoot j'ai
tout connu moi en jeu vidéo alors
pourquoi de chercher moi aussi j'ai fait
du tennis aussi une fois sur la wii de
la stop us batman assassin's creed mon
expérience est à peu près au niveau 2 0
avec je vais devoir battre mes petits
camarades petits camarades pas moi qui
l'inventé on m'a vraiment brillé comme
ça bah je l'affronté mes petits
camarades au jeu dont j'ai oublié le nom
blad aucune idée ce que ça veut dire
bouillon de sang non mais il faut tuer
des gens c'est ça malheureux faut mettre
les dragonnes attend on va péter la télé
vraiment les gars ça fait un petit truc
quand est passé de la game gear à ça ça
fait très bizarre à temps qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
attendez là c'est le truc qui fait peur
quand même fait pas long ils me font
flipper alala non mais j'aime pas j'ai
tué des gens [ __ ] m'a fait peur en q
je pense qu'il me dit un truc du genre à
temps c'est débile mes bras sont comme
ça quand je fais comme ça ils inversion
merci à toi je suis chaud rien que ça
c'est très flippant
hé les gars c'est tellement bien feu
sékou c'est mieux que disney long des
chemins another one [ __ ] the dust
hockey
j'ai trop peur je n'ai pas eu trop peur
je peux le faire mais il faut que je
voie le réel avec faut que je mette un
peu bancal non parce que là vous m'avez
menti sept jeux qui fait peur suit
lorsque vous pouvez me parler ou [ __ ]
c'est juste le temps de chargement à à
l'heure du temps de chargement faire
d'effort et adapte au pape et au salut
toi papa l'air en forme
about leur parti ok un petit moon walk
faut vraiment que je les tue les gens je
suis obligé sinon chez je suis menacé ou
pas ok tout va bien je suis terrorisée
non tout est flou pedrorist [ __ ] au
plus tard le 13
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde j'ai
peur d'éclairer un truc et que d'un coup
il ya une tête alors non ça va pas
arriver ils sont déjà passés les
bonshommes les premiers bons hommes
personne à gauche parce qu'il ya
peut-être un bonhomme l'autre gauche
mais pourquoi cela n'éclaire pas bien
chez elle
mais qu'est ce que c'est c'est une
véritable porcherie ici nickel ça me
donne envie de bouffer du bacon c'est
clairement pas pour les vegan faut tirer
sur les sites je suis un score de mer en
fait gérés complets au jeu à l'étoile
rouge voilà absolument à l'est ce qui se
passe
il ya des cochons partout ça saigne
bah ouais talent quoi toi sale fort et
je dois tirer sur les étoiles messari
fort il ya des espèces de au [ __ ] y'a
plus le bien plus généreux non non non
ça va être horrible et rétro et je ferme
les yeux
mais [ __ ] nul chez vous vous étiez
vous tous
ah [ __ ] de ta mère non mais c'est
horrible c'est horrible je suis
extrêmement stressé j'ai envie de
chialer le petit roller coaster de bas
étage c'est un peu un mix entre donkey
kong country voir à plein dans l'âme il
est bien which ça ça va ça c'est disney
je connais et j'ai même le la sensation
du coeur qui remonte
j'ai vraiment la chair que j'ai
l'impression que le sejil en train de
bouger
aulas l'a tous fait flipper [ __ ] c'est
dingue je transpire la écoute sept
maisons à loix caresse ça doit faire un
bon 75
je vais pas la prendre carrément
maintenir à huy faut tirer que sur ce qu
a dit non bah ils m'envoient toute la
vaisselle ni 4 il pleut il ya des
humains il y avait que le logo de mort
passent le cap
toi tu casses toi tu captes doivent
revenir l'échelle ho [ __ ] mais quand
je fais ça ça me fait flipper à chaque
fois [ __ ] mais c'est vous qui me
touche
sochaux mais qu'elle met ainsi qu'une 12
mois
[Musique]
ah c'est ça [ __ ] mais j'ai eu peur on
score est de 20 milles 64,23 1185 moi
j'espère juste avoir battu un record
18000 77000 à 1605 j'ai fait dix-huit
mille cent soixante dix cents millions
six cent des salles il arrête de mentir
c'est génial on en prend plein la gueule
tu me suis pris pour un super héros pour
un cow boy pour tout ce que tu veux
c'est une tueriie ça fait super peur
face j'ai sursauté réellement d'issue
possible afin de provoquer un an moi je
déteste c'est la pire semaine de ma vie
hyper immersif mais c'est horrible il ya
7 litres de sueur sur ce casque moi ce
qui me plaît dans les jeux vidéo c'est
le fait que ce soit des jeux et que ce
soit pas réel quoi là c'est trop réel
c'est black mirror quoi je déteste
surtout monde c'est valentin si vous
avez adoré cette vidéo n'hésitez surtout
pas à vous abonner sur la chaîne de
golden moustache alors pourquoi quoi
encore qu'est ce que tu fais ben je
parle vite c'est comme ça qu'on fait
dans le gaming oui tu veux dire tu
copies sur squeeze ce quick est ce cui
cui qui sonne bien
ok y'a tout le monde sait ce cookie si
vous avez adoré cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à vous adresser à la cdu en fait oui
mais ce cui qui sait bien